le dossier de la rédaction ce soir
préparé par alexandra marie est
consacrée à l'histoire mouvementée
d'irlande du nord les négociations pour
aboutir à un tel gouvernement d'union
ont débuté il ya dix ans pour mettre fin
définitivement aux violences qui ont
fait 3500 morts
bloody sunday le dimanche sanglant le 30
janvier 1972 et l'armée britannique tire
sur la foule des manifestants
catholiques
ils réclament l'égalité avec les
protestants et la réunification de
l'irlande entre se meurt sous les balles
oui il était drogué car aucun être
humain n'aurait pu faire cela tu es mon
fils tué des innocents sur les restes
des barricades des drapeaux noirs c'est
ici que les treize manifestants ont été
tués dans la rue le sentiment
d'injustice nourrit la volonté de
vengeance
ayew va être violent
non je ne l'étais pas devenu vieux coup
si vous pouviez tué un soldat le feriez
vous actuellement les menus l'ira
l'armée républicaine irlandaise appel à
la guerre civile
ouvertement et sur les ondes nous allons
vous pour chausser et vous périrez tous
le quartier catholique de belfast le
bogside plonge dans le chaos
les affrontements entre les émeutiers et
l'armée sont quotidiens les attentats
meurtriers se multiplient en irlande et
le terrorisme frappe jusqu'en
grande-bretagne mais le gouvernement
britannique refuse de céder
les membres de l'ira sont envoyés en
prison comme celle que les républicains
appellent longue pêche en 81 ils
réclament le statut de prisonnier
politique et entame une grève de la faim
bobby sands leur leader ainsi que dix
autres membres de l'ira en mourront tout
au long des années 80 la guerre civile
se poursuit aux actions de l'ira
répondent les violences des ministres
protestants mais en 97 lire annonce une
trêve guéret adams le chef du shin fine
la branche politique de l'organisation
et son bras droit
martin mcguinness sont reçus par tony
blair le 10 avril 1998 jour historique
les accords dits du vendredi saint john
à l'irlande du nord
de nouvelles institutions mais la peine
durera que quatre mois un attentat
revendiqué par les dissidents de l'ira
29 morts le tournant se produire en 2005
l'ira déposent les armes c'est peut-être
le jour prenre ou après les fausses
espérances aux deux font tourner les
espoirs déçus
pis la paix remplace la guerre aux et la
politique remplaçait que le terrorisme
sur les skis relais et c'est bien par la
voie des urnes que l'irlande du nord
parvient aujourd'hui à la paix les
résultats des élections parlementaires
du mois dernier oblige
désormais les catholiques et les
protestants a décidé ensemble de
l'avenir du pays